Speaker 1: So the mayor of Philadelphia is
Jim Kenney, and he is being attacked very
significantly right now because he said, you
know what, I look forward to not being mayor
so I can stop worrying about these constant mass
shootings. I told you that it was a disastrous 4th
of July weekend in the United States, something
like 13, 14, 15 mass shootings in the United
States over the 4th of July weekend. Two major,
major ones, it's crazy to say in the U.S. we have
major mass shootings and then we have minor mass
shootings which don't make national headlines
necessarily. Two of the major mass shootings we
had, one was in the Chicago suburb of Highland
Park. The other was in Philadelphia during
a fireworks display for the 4th of July. And
after the shooting in which two police
officers were shot during the fireworks
show and concert at the Ben Franklin Parkway in
Philadelphia, the mayor of Philly, Jim Kenney,
said, I'm up all night. Every time we have
a large event, I'm staring at the ceiling,
worried about a mass shooting. I look
forward to no longer being the mayor.
And this caught some people by surprise.
Always not appropriate. The mayor doesn't
even want to be mayor. That doesn't sound good.
No, it's not good. And I completely sympathize
with Jim Kenney. Here's what he had to say.
Speaker 3: I am because I'm honest, I'm concerned
every single day there's not an event or a
day where I don't lay on my back and look
at the ceiling and wonder if worry about stuff.
So everything we have in the city over the last
seven years, I worry about I don't enjoy 4th
of July. I don't enjoy the the the Democratic
National Convention. I enjoy the the NFL draft.
I'm waiting for something bad to happen all the
time. So I'll be happy when I'm not here, when
I'm the mayor and I could enjoy some stuff. So
you're looking forward to not being mayor? Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's what you're looking forward. Who
not being mayor. Yeah. And who could possibly
disagree with what he's saying? The guns are
absolutely everywhere. No matter what he does in
Philly. Pennsylvania has rules and the surrounding
states have rules. And it's so easy to get almost
whatever you want. And so whenever there's a
mass event, 4th of July, whatever he's saying, is
this going to be the one where we are the target?
And yesterday they had one of those incidents.
So I don't really understand the criticism. He's
not saying he doesn't care about Philadelphia.
He's not saying he doesn't care about the people
of the city or whatever. He's saying the toll
that it is taking that whenever we do anything,
I'm up at night staring at the ceiling, wondering,
is this the one where a shooter shows up? Is this
the one and he can't take it? And that makes
sense. Many of us can't take it. It's absolutely
horrifying what's going on. So Jim can he's
fine. There's there's no there's no bigs. Oh,
God. We've got to remove him. He says he
doesn't want to be mayor. He's looking forward
to when it is not on him, that
at anything he does in the city,
there could be another outcropping of this
plague that we have in the United States of mass
shootings and shooters. So that's Jim Carrey. And
I very much identify with the way he's feeling.